Hello everyone.  So today we are going to talk about Zika virus.
We are going talk about mosquitoes.  We're going to talk about pregnancy.
We are also going to focus on what you, the high school student, can do and should be doing to protect yourself from mosquito bites.
So I want to start today and talk
about the World Health Organization
and you'll see that WHO stands for the
World Health Organization.
And the World Health Organisation announced, on the first of February this year,
a public health emergency of international concern.  We've only ever had four,
and this was the fourth.  Our first one was in April 2009 when we had pandemic influenza or pandemic flu.
In May of 2014 we had another emergency for polio.
In August of 2014, we had an emergency for Ebola.  And I had three trips to West Africa
setting up Ebola hospitals and treating Ebola patients.  And then on the 1st of February
this year, in 2016, we had another public
health emergency.
And this wasn't because of the mosquitoes, this wasn't related to the virus, this is because in Brazil
they were seeing babies born with what's
called microcephaly,
or their heads were much smaller than they should be.
And then something amazing happened because
when this announcement, when this announcement  and this emergency happened  on the first of February,
we didn't know a lot about the Zika virus.  We didn't know about, a lot about,
the Zika virus and the effect it would
have on pregnant women,
let alone the effect it would have on unborn babies. And on April 13th, only a few weeks ago
this year, a new study was published by
colleagues of mine from the Center for
Disease Control in Atlanta, Georgia.  And
here's a copy of this paper that's freely
available on the internet for you to
read.  And they published the first
evidence that Zika virus was related to birth defects and how it affected pregnant women.
So we now know today, we now know that
the Zika virus infects, can infect
pregnant women, and can somehow
get into those babies and cause birth
defects.  And the birth, the main birth defect
we're seeing is called microcephaly.  And
this slide I want to show you what a
typical head size of a baby looks like.  A
baby with microcephaly has a head size
that's smaller than normal and a baby
with severe microcephaly has a much very
much smaller head size.  Now why do they
have smaller head sizes?  Because we now know
that the Zika virus attacks the brain and
the Zika virus affects the growth and development of the brain.
And babies fetuses that are in the mother, in the womb,
before they are  born, as the brain grows the head grows.
Now if you have a virus like Zika that
attacks the brain, the head doesn't grow
as fast and that's why we're getting
babies born with smaller head sizes.
But we're also seeing other problems at the
moment.  We will see seeing babies that
are born, and these very newborn babies, these young infants, we are seeing
problems with their eyes, with their sight.  We are seeing problems with their hearing.  We are seeing
problems with their growth and
development.  And so there's still a lot
we need to learn about the effects of
Zika virus
and the effects of that has on pregnant women, on fetuses, and on newborn babies.
And the way that we measure this is we take a tape measure when the baby's born.  So we wait 24 hours
after the baby's born, we put a tape
measure around their head,
and we measure the size of their head.
But it's really important that when we worked with the nurses,
with the doctors, with the community health workers around the world that I work with
that they all take the same measurements.
So we are doing lots of course and lots of
training at the moment to teach nurses
and doctors and community health workers
how to take this measurement.  And we can
see that, by putting a tape measure
around the head, whether the head is normal or below normal.  And then we'll repeat
this every week, and will repeat this for
a number of years, to look at the
development of the baby.  And this is
really important.
Another way that we can diagnose what's
called microcephaly before the baby
is born is by taking ultrasounds.
Now the the emergency we have so far
is so large that we don't have time to
go and teach everyone in the world how
to read these ultrasounds.  So what we do,
we get them to take an ultrasound of the
pregnant woman, and then we use
telemedicine like we doing today.
The same video conferencing software that
you are using today we use for them to show
us what the ultrasound of the pregnant
woman's baby looks like.  And then we get
other physicians and nurses who are much
better, much more expert in the field of
ultrasound, and they help them diagnose
whether the baby has a small head.
Since that emergency's been announced the first of February I've been on TV a number of times.
I've been on CNN. I've been on the BBC. I've been on Canada CTV. I've been on Al-jazeera.
And the challenge that I face as a public health expert is, that like this one here on Al-jazeera,
Zika virus fears. More Americans test positive after traveling.
What I want to tell you today there's nothing to be scared about.
And we have to ensure that people are
educated, they're aware, and they
understand what the Zika virus is, how
it's transmitted by mosquitoes, how do we
protect ourselves, and what we need to do
to decrease that risk.  And it's so
important that we not scared about this
but we were actually we take action, and we
do the right thing to protect us from
being bitten by mosquitoes.
And here is a map of Brazil, and this is where it all started about May 2015.
We've known about the Zika virus since 1947.  It comes from a very beautiful forests in the country of
Uganda, in Africa.  And it really hasn't
been related to causing birth defects in
babies for many - until very recently -
about 12 months ago.
And it started in Brazil and here, in Brazil, you can see the red dots, and the red dots show where
these babies that are being born with
small heads actually started being reported in 2015;
and that's why the World Health Organization in Februaryof this year announced the  emergency.
And what we've seen, very rapidly, very quickly, the
spread of the Zika virus,
not just as we've seen it before in
Africa and Asia; but when it appeared in
Brazil, it spread all through other
countries in South America.  It went to
Central America, it went to the Caribbean,
it's now in the Pacific Islands.  It's
been there before, but it's going back
there now.  It's in Hawaii, for example.
We've had met people that have traveled
to Samoan people will travel to Brazil
and come back to Hawaii.  We don't see local transmission so it's not in the mosquito
population, but it's starting to appear in
many countries throughout the world.
And we're at nearly sixty countries right
now where the mosquitoes are transmitting
Zika virus, but not here in the United
States.  The cases that we've had here in
the United States have just been from
people traveling to any of these
countries here that are colored in blue.
So if we look at the information that we have
today here in the United States, the
Centers for Disease Control Atlanta
tells us that we have laboratory confirmed these are people that have been sick, gone to a
doctor, had a blood sample, and the blood
samples being sent to a laboratory and
have tested positive for the Zika virus, we have 388
cases.  Some of those have been in
pregnant women.
All of those cases, all of the
388, have traveled outside the US to
countries with known Zika virus.
In the US territories is a little bit different;
the story is a little bit different.
We've had 503 known laboratory
confirmed cases - America Samoa,
Puerto Rico, and the US Virgin Islands.  Now
those three countries are different
because the virus is now in their mosquito
populations, and it's possible, if you
live in Porto Rico, the US Virgin Islands, or
American Samoa, if you're bitten by
a mosquito, you may be able to get this
Zika virus.
And we're really concerned about two types of mosquitoes,
and these two types of mosquitoes are really easy to identify.
The first one is the Aedes
aegypti mosquito and it really is it's not
native here in the US.  It actually
came from Africa, but it has been here, it
doesn't live here now in the US, and we
sometimes
call this the yellow fever mosquito.
The other mosquito we are worried about is the Aedes
albopictus which comes from Asia, and it
now lives here in the United States, and
we call that the Asian tiger mosquito.
And these mosquitoes in your backyard, in
your home, where you live, are really easy
to identify.  Have a look closely at these
two photos.  Can you see their legs?
Can you see the white stripes?
Aides species mosquito have white stripes on their legs.  So if you're at your house your home and
you see those mosquitos and they don't
have any stripes,
then they're not the Aedes type.  But if they do have white stripes, then they belong to
Aides species of mosquito, and they're the
mosquitoes we are worried about.
And the Center for Disease Control, the CDC, in Atlanta, Georgia has produced two maps -
and here's the first map on the left
is the Aedes aegypti, that first mosquito
we looked at, and these are the states in
the middle of summer where these
mosquitoes have been found in previous
years.  The Aedes albopictus mosquito is
shown on the map on the right hand side
and you can see the states where they,
we know they live.  But that doesn't show us
the risk.  And what it shows is here is
that there's going to be about 30 states in
the US this year that are going to have
the right mosquitoes to spread the virus.
But they may not spread the virus and
I'm going to show you why.
So first of all let's look at and talk a little bit about risk.
If we go back to this these, these maps that are on the CDC website, it doesn't really
tell us is a mosquito in my backyard?
Does it live?  Because the mosquito
doesn't live at high altitudes.  It lives
at altitudes down where it is warm and it's hot,
it's wet.  And it doesn't live at areas where above 6,500 feet and
it's not shown on this map.
A study that came out two days ago by NASA actually
took all the information we've had from
previous years and started to generate
maps based on risk by month.  And let's
look here, the Aedes aegypti mosquito,
and we know in winter it's cold and
mosquitoe is not around.
But we know that in May, June, July, August, and September, can you see those dots?
The red, the orange dot is high, the yellow dot is low risk and shows with these mosquitoes have been
found and where we're going to see risk.  But it doesn't take us down to a local level
and what's really interesting is that,
even though we may have the mosquito
present, it doesn't mean it's going to
transmit the virus.
And this is why.
Because in the US, the only way that
mosquito can get infected is if the
mosquito bites someone that already has
the infection, and that's a really
important message to understand.  You
got to understand that for the mosquito to
get infected, it has to bite someone that
has the infection, and they have the virus
in the blood.  And we all know that
mosquitoes, when they bite us, they are sucking blood.
These mosquitoes, the Aedes aegypti and Aedes albopictus, can also
transmit other viruses.  And you may have
heard of diseases like yellow fever.
We give a vaccination for that.  You may have heard of diseases like dengue.  There's been a
dengue outbreak for the last six months
in Hawaii.  You may have heard of diseases
like chikungunya, which is a new disease
for the last couple of years, and again
that's spread by the same mosquito. Zika is
spread by these mosquitoes.  And so this
mosquito has to bite someone that is infected before can transmit the virus to someone else,
and this is how it does it.  The
mosquito bites a person with the infection.
These mosquitoes mainly bite in the day so
we were really, really looking for
mosquitoes that bite in the day, but don't be
fooled by that.  These mosquitoes can also
bite at night.  We get these mosquitoes
here in Washington, DC, and I know last
year I got bitten when I was out having
a BBQ with my family.  We get bitten even
when it's dark, so they're not just
daytime biters.  When they bite you, they
suck in the blood that takes in the
virus, the Zika virus.  It goes down to
their stomach, their gut.  It then enters
their bloodstream, their circuitry system,
and it goes back up to their salivary
glands, which is in their mouth part
their proboscis.  Then, when they take
the next bite, when they inject saliva,
that's where the virus is.  This cycle
in the mosquito takes about 10 days.
So even if a mosquito bites an infected person, it's about 10 days before that mosquito
can transmit the virus.  Which of these
mosquitoes actually bite?  Guess what?
The males don't bite; the boy mosquitoes
don't bite.  It's the female mosquitoes.
The female mosquitoes are the ones that
bite us.  And it's really important now
that what we are doing in communities - and I've been doing a lot of work with high
schools in South America and Central
America, even here in the US, in states
like Georgia, Alabama, and Tennessee and
Florida - we are getting students now to
actually help us identify where these
mosquitoes with white bands on their legs
are actually there.  Are they in your
neighborhood?  And the reason we doing this
is, as we know that these mosquitoes
don't fly very far.
They fly about the length of a football field, about a hundred and fifty feet.  So if you find
mosquitoes with white legs in your
backyard, they fly about the length of a
football field, and then they'll come back
in the evening and they really stay locally.
And so we can control these mosquitoes locally, then we can decrease the risk of Zika virus.
This slide here shows what's been
happening a lot in medicine.  Public
health hospitals have been using this for years.
We reproduce what's called infographics and this is an infographic produced by the
CDC which focuses on not just Zika, but
chikungunya, and dengue.
And here this infographic is explaining what local transmission.
Remember we talked about the mosquitoes in Puerto Rico,
American Samoa, the US Virgin Islands.
Local transmission is occurring in those three countries.  Local transmissions not
occurring in the US 48 states, also Hawaii
and Alaska.  So here where local
transmission, you gotta understand this term, is where mosquito bites a person who's
infected again we know takes about 10 days for the bars to go through the mosquito,
then the mosquito then bites someone who's healthy
and they inject the virus in the saliva.
Now within three to seven days that person may become sick.
But we  know with Zika virus not everyone's going to become sick,
only some people will.
What we're having here in the United States right now is what's called an imported case of Zika, and these
important cases where someone goes on
for business trip, goes on vacation, down
to those countries I showed on the map that are blue, they get bitten by a mosquito that
has the Zika virus.  Within three to seven
days they may feel sick, some may feel sick,
and they come back to the US and
we diagnose them through a laboratory
tests they have the virus, and that's called,
that's a imported case, and that's what
we're seeing now the United States.  What
we're concerned about is getting local
transmission, as we get more of these
mosquitoes in spring and summer,
and the potential for getting more people infected with this Zika virus leading to local transmission.
And when we talked about people getting sick from the Zika virus,
they really have four symptoms we're going to focus on.  They get a fever.
They get a rash.  They could have joint pain, but not always.
They could have red eyes, which we call
conjunctivitis, and it's very similar to
these other diseases that are transmitted by mosquitoes called dengue and chikungunya.
What makes these three
diseases unique here in the United
States is these are nationally
notifiable diseases or national notifiable conditions.
So that if you're sick, and
you go to see your physician, your doctor,
or nurse, and they test you and that test
comes back positive, by law,
by legislation, they have to report this
disease to the local county health
department, who then reports them to the
state health department, who then reports it
to the Center for Disease Control Atlanta.  And that's what we mean by nationally notifiable diseases.
And I just recently come back from South America.
I went to five countries. I saw a
lot of people that were sick
and i can tell you now that not everyone had all these four symptoms.
Nearly everyone had fever, but not
everyone had rash.
Nearly everyone had fever, and some had red eyes or conjunctivitis,
but not everyone.  So this is still a very challenging disease for us to diagnose.
When you look at what do we do.  How do we protect ourselves?
Now you could be sick Zika.  You could be sick with chikungunya.  You could be sick with dengue.
But it's really important that we have to
take responsibility for ourselves and
protect ourselves.  And it's really
important that, if we have these symptoms,
that over that seven-day period where we
may be able to transmit the virus to
mosquitoes, we have to prevent ourselves
from being bitten by mosquitoes.
And the ways that we can do that - well, we know that daytime is the most likely time for
these mosquitoes to bite.  These mosquitoes with white bands on their legs
most  likely bite in the day time, especially when the sun comes up  at dawn
and when the sun goes in the dust.  But
remember, it's not always the case,
they can bite at the night time, so we got to  protect ourselves.
We might want to protectourselves with clothing - socks, long pair of trousers, shirts, long shirts - from being bitten.
We want to use insect repellent.
And so one of the questions that I get
asked, I teach at both Harvard University
and Penn State University, when all our
students were going on spring break, one
of the questions that all the students
asked me was, "Hey we're going on spring
break.  Do we put our sunscreen on first
or our insect repellent on first?"
And it's a really good question, and you put the sunscreen on first and then you put the
insect repellent on second, and not many
people know that, but that's the way you do it.
Again we can wear protective
clothing, but we can also, what we can do
as individuals, within our families, we
can mosquito proof our homes.
We can decrease the likelihood of the
mosquitoes laying their eggs, reproducing
around our homes, and we can decrease the risk of being bitten by a  mosquito.
So what the Center for Disease Control -
New York has done this, Florida has done this,
Alabama, California, Louisiana, Hawaii's
doing this - they putting together the
prevention kits.  And the work that I've
been doing in high schools is actually
helping them raise some money.  We know
that we can put these kits together.
They have a bed net.  They have these little larvae site tablets where we can put them in water and
it kills the mosquito larvae.  We have
some deet, or some insect repellent that
it is known to work, and there is a list of those we can provide.  We used the Methrin spray
on our clothes.  We don't put it on our skin.
We put it on our clothes.  We know that we can
take out temperature in case we have a
fever.  We now know that Zika can be
transmitted sexually from men to women through semen, so we can provide
condoms.  And it's really interesting, because
high school students that I've been working  with
with have been putting through these kits
and selling them to people in their
community - one, to raise the awareness of
mosquitoes and the potential getting
Zika, but also to make some money.  And I
had some students knock on my door in
Washington, DC just recently and they were selling these at $20 each and I thought what a
great idea that was.  Did I needed it?  No. But did I pay the $20? I sure did.  So I
really liked their initiative and we
started doing this in the countries I
went to in South America.  And the nice
thing is that the Center for Disease
Control has actually made this really
easy for you.  You make this kit.  You put in
a bag.  You sell it for twenty dollars.  And
they've even
printed information that you can copy,
download from the website,
print out, and hand out to the
families that you sold the kits to,
and it tells them how to use the kit.  So all
the information you need is there.
And again, I have two children.  They're
both in middle school and this is what
they are going to do in the summer break - focus on selling Zika kits.
So let's look
at the mosquito life cycle, and this is
really important to understanding the
risk of transmission of Zika.
We know it's not the male mosquito; it's the
female mosquito that bites us.  So we only get
bitten by female mosquitoes.
They lay eggs in water and they,
what's really remarkable about these Aedes
mosquitoes, they can lay their eggs in a
very small amount of water, and the eggs
can either hatch or they can survive for many, many months.  And we know here in Washington, DC
that we have mosquitoes that lay their
eggs, they survive the winter, they
survive the snow, and it's still there
in the spring and the summer and they hatch out.
Usually these eggs though, they hatch, you know, in a few days in a few days to a few months,
and they produce what's called
larvae.  Those larvae, within 5 days,
go to pupae, and those pupae then live in the water and the develop into young
flying mosquitoes in 2 to 3 days.
And then takes a few weeks for those mosquitoes, those
flying mosquitoes, then to mature where they can actually transmitted the virus.
But if you understand the mosquito life cycle, then you also understand
the second opportunity I want to give high school students, and things that you can do.
And one of those you can do is help the local county health department,
or the local mosquito vector
control program, in identifying
where there are eggs, where there are a larvae, where there are pupae, where there are young
adult mosquitoes hatching in water, and
where there is actually mosquitoes with white
bands on the legs actually biting people.  And you can see the five photos here
show you those life cycles.
And so what we've done throughout community
engagement, through using high school
students, we've actually started programs
where they can go out and help the
community.  And it's really important
because we know how to control
mosquitoes.  We're just not really good at
it, because we don't take, we don't pay much
attention.  But this year we've really
got to focus on how to control mosquitoes
because we have this risk of this, of this
Zika virus.  And we know that pot
plants are going to have water.  We know that
there are swimming pools.  We know there are areas that, like car tires, that
contain water where the mosquitoes can
breed. We know that if we see any water,
we have to drain it and tip it out and
get rid of it.  We know that we put
flowers in vases.  Over a very short
period of time,
mosquitos could lay their eggs there.  We
know that any barrels,
containers, buckets that we have in the back yard or front yard that have water, we have
to put a lid on top of them.  And we also
know that we have to protect our homes.
Whether we've got air conditioning or we don't have air conditioning, how do we put insect
screens on the wall, on the on
the windows, on the doors, and keep them
closed to ensure the mosquitoes don't
come inside?
So here in the US,
at every county, at every city, in every town, there are mosquito surveillance programs on
going right now, and they can really
use your help.  And from the five
countries I went to in South America, they had mosquito surveillance programs and we
engage the students from the high schools
down there to actually help those programs.
And what these mosquitoes
surveillance programs do, they estimate
the number of mosquitoes, the mosquito
abundance in the area.  Remember those mosquitoes
only fly a hundred and fifty feet, or
about the length of a football field
from where they actually breed, so they
don't fly miles.  We use the estimates by
counting the mosquitoes in their life
cycle - eggs, pupae, larvae, and adults- and we
indicate the levels of risk at the
local neighborhood level.
And then we do this maybe every day, every week, so we can compare the results over time and location.
We put them on maps.
So, again, you could take a real important role
yourself in your community and where
you live by helping your local county
health department, or your local mosquito
vector control program, by doing larvae
and pupea surveys, by this little
traps that we can get that trap catch
eggs and we can also get sticky traps
that catch adult mosquitoes, and
we can identify do they have what bands
on their legs and, if they do, we report them.
And what do we do with that information?
Well, we've had mosquito diseases that
have been transferred by mosquito.  We've had them
for years here in the US.  We had West Nile
virus.  And here's a map of New York
where, not just the government, but also
the schools in New York, helped set out some
traps and help send in information every
day.  And the way they did that, they used
their cellphones. I'm going to show you how we use cell phones to send in the
critical, that really important
information, that's needed.  And this is a
map of New York  which showed
with the traps were laid out for
West Nile virus.  And they took all that
information every day, and they produced
these heat maps. These maps are
risk maps, and you can see the darker the color,
the higher the concentration or
the higher the number of mosquitoes,
so therefore, the higher risk.  And places like New York City, New York State, places like
Florida, Georgia, Alabama, California, Hawaii are producing these maps every day to show us the risk.
So again, you could participate and help identify mosquitoes on a daily basis,
and then call in to the county health department
and let them know the result of what you find.
The other project, the third project, we set up in South America with high school students
was that we know how to kill mosquitoes, we use insecticides,
but the big problem we have that sometimes over
time we use the same insecticides over and over again, we get what's called resistance,
and mosquitoes who develop resistance
don't die that well form using insecticides.
So one of the projects we
set up was with students was taking a
glass jar, capturing mosquitoes.  You
put the insecticide around the glass jar,
catch the mosquitoes, and you leave them there for an hour and you count how many of those mosquitos died.
If they die, then we show that the mosquito insecticide is working.
If they didn't die, then we got to
call the county health department say -
"Hey, look at this; the mosquitoes didn't die" - and we're going to work out why.  That's
information we can find.  It doesn't
cost much money to get a glass jar and
conduct these experiments, so it's a really
good science experiment.
The Center for Disease Control has actually published the protocols, the procedures, of how to
set up these experiments.  And this is a
picture taken from the manual that's available
on the website, available online, to do
this.
And I want to give you a real world example now.  This is Orange County in California.
This is their vector control program.
And taken from their website this morning, they have a big sign up
"We need your help!"
And they want every
citizen, they want
every person, throughout the whole
neighborhood, throughout the community, to
report that, if they get bitten or they see
mosquitoes biting you in the daytime,
to ring this number.  That's a really
good idea and we're seeing counties and
towns and cities throughout the country do this and setup these programs.
But the thing is high school students,
a lot of you have these, the phones.
So why do we, why do we want to make a phone call?  Why don't we use an app?
Why don't we send a text message? Why don't we use social media?  Why don't we use
Facebook or Twitter or WhatsApp?
And this is really important for Ebola disease.
For the nurses to communicate, we used WhatsApp.  What we set up now for
students is an actual using an app
to actually report.  So you don't actually have to
make a phone call and talk to a person.  You can actually just
record it on your phone like a text message and send it in to their surveillance system.
And this is what
we've done, and for the app you can
download and you can put in on your phone looks something like this.  It'll have your name, has your
address, has your phone number
tells you, well, probably at my house, are there dogs on the property because that's really important.
When the mosquito control people
come out, they want to know whether these
dogs are around in your yard so they don't get bitten.
"Where did you see the mosquito?"  "Oh, we saw them around the oak trees."
Maybe you might got a photo of it.  If you got a photo, you can send the photo on the app.
And it's really important that we know the
location of where you are when you send in your report.
And many of us don't have
to try very hard to send in the location,
because this is a really cool app, and I want you to Google this.  Whenever I get home work to my
my son and my daughter who are in middle
school
and I try to tell them let's do your homework, they go "Dad can't we just Google it?"
And so what you can do, if you can Google "What Three Words" and What Three Words is on the website,
has a website.  It also has an app.
What Three Word has taken the world
and  has divided the world up into squares that are 9 feet by 9 feet and they've put
three words for every square.  Now to cover the
whole globe
it takes fifty seven trillion squares.
So they have taken fifty seven trillion squares
9 feet by 9 feet,
given them a three-word
identification, and you can now use their app
to identify where you are when you
see a mosquito, or when you see an egg,
or when you see pupae or larvae, or something else
you want to report.  If you send me those
three words to my phone I would then be
out to identify exactly where you are,
where your square is, 9 feet by 9 feet.
And we use this all the time.
It's a really easy way for us to put
information on a map and it's called What Three Words.
So in Orange County
this is what they are doing as people either
call in information or send in information.
Everyday they are making maps.  And this is
one of the maps and, as you can see, the
red areas is where this Aedes aegypti
mosquitoes are being found and the yellow
areas is where Aedes albopictus
mosquitoes are being found.  And they put this on the
Internet, on the website, so that every
person in the community can check this
website and they know where the
mosquitoes have been found the previous day.
So I've given you a couple of projects
that high school students can do.  Ive given you a
couple of ways that you can make some
money over the summer.
I just want to talk about - there are lots of things that we know, but they're still many more things
that we don't know about this Zika virus, and we're learning every day.
So just to summarize what we know.
Zika  can be spread from a pregnant woman to her unborn baby, the fetus, during pregnancy, we know that.
We now know, as of April 13,
this is only very new scientific
information, that the infection in
pregnancy can be linked to birth defects.
But there's still a lot to learn about
that.
We know that the Zika is spread mostly by the bite of an infected Aedes species mosquito.
These are these mosquitoes with white bands on their legs.
And even though these mosquitoes mainly bite in the day, they can also bite at night time.
We also know today
that the Zika virus is not locally transmitted by mosquitoes in the US 48 continental states,
it's not in Alaska, it's not in Hawaii either.
But we do know those mosquitos are found here.  And because these mosquitoes
that spread ,or can spread Zika, are found through many countries throughout the world,
we're going to see many more countries experience Zika outbreaks.
The last thing that we know is that there is no vaccine for Zika and there's no
medicine or treatment for Zika.  We have to
treat the symptoms,
but there's no actual cure for Zika, and
that's really important to understand.
A couple of things that we don't know and
we'll research on that scientists are
working on right now today.  When is there
a safe time during the nine months of
pregnancy to travel to an area with Zika?
When there is a safe time when you might be
infected with Zika over your nine months of
pregnancy?  We don't know.
If you do travel to an area where there is local Zika transmission and you're bitten, we don't know how
likely you are to get Zika.  We can't tell
you that.  We just don't know,
and we also don't know that, if you're
female and you're pregnant and you get
bitten, we don't know how likely your
baby is to have birth defects.
We have seen birth defects.  We're very concerned
about them, but we don't know how likely
you are to get - your baby to have birth defects, if you are  infected by this Zika virus, and this
is really important.  So when I went to
five countries in South America to help
hospitals, to help patients, to help the
doctors and nurses, and I work with high
school students, we came up with some
programs.  And it's really easy because we
have phones, we have the Internet, and ways
of communication.  So for all of us it's
easier than ever right now for us to
communicate, collaborate, connect.
And it's essential for us, as citizens in here in
the United States, to actually help out
government, to help out local health
department, to help out local mosquito
control program, to provide them
information that they don't have the
resources to get on a day-to-day basis.
And we can do that really easily.
So thank you everyone for listening.
Do you have any questions or comments for Dr. Macgregor-Skinner?
We have a question.
We can just ask.
Who's going to ask the question?
In the back, can you stand up so I can see you?
Ok.
No he can do it.
You can talk right there.  The mic is here.
If you want him to see you, look at the camera.
All right, is it more likely for people to get bitten by a mosquito?
Like, like, how can I pit this?
Like is is it more likely in Los Angles for people to get bitten by a mosquito?
That's a really good question because only a few years ago
these types of mosquitoes weren't really found in California,
but they had been recently, and they have been when we had the West Nile virus outbreak.
So we now know.  In California we call these invasive species of mosquitoes.
And so it's really important like an Orange County,
in LA, and everywhere else, that we
actually get together as a community and
we try to help the local county health
department and mosquito program
to actually identify where these types of
Aedes mosquitoes, the ones with the white bands,
are actually where they are, cause we really don't know, and we need to get
as much of information as we can.
Now when you have these mosquitoes,
the mosquito doesn't, doesn't pick who they
want to bite.  They just bite us.  They'll bite anyone.
And what's really interesting, these mosquitoes only bite people.
And it's so no matter we're outside and the mosquitoes in the area, they going to find us.
When theyfind us, they're going to try to bite us, especially during the day time.  So it's really
important, for this spring and this summer,
that we first of all we identify where
the mosquitoes are and if they are, we always try to prevent them from
breeding and for being with us.  We try to
control them.  We need to prevent them
from laying their eggs and for those
eggs, as I showed you in the life cycle, from going through
their life cycle.  But if we do find, if we
find adult mosquitoes with white bands on their legs,
one of the really cool things we can do is set up a program to help the county health
department, like Orange County's doing, to
actually report, and it's called like
citizen reporting.  We can report every
day that whether we did or did not find
mosquitoes around our house.  And that's
really important because we know that if
the mosquitoes are there, we go outside,
they'll find us really easy, and they are  going to want to
bite, as they need to bite us to get
that blood.
Thank you.  Good question.
We have another question.  Um, well you say that mosquitoes only bite humans, but in one of your slides you were like make sure there's not a dog outside.
What will happen if.....  Well the dog is going to attack the person who may be coming to
look at the mosquito.  Oh, oh, okay.  But I wondered that too.  So they don't bite animals; they only bite humans?
They've evolved over the time with people. And wherever we've moved, that mosquitoes
follows us.  This is mosquito that has evolved
to live with us.
The Aedes albopictus is very similar, but
it is a little different.  It does bite
animals.  It will bite our dog.  It will bite our pet cat, but we don't know what the role or is there any role at
all Zika virus can affect our dog or cat.  We
don't know that and we don't know
that whether the Zika virus actually can be transmitted from a dog to mosquito.  We don't know that and it's
highly unlikely.  What we really concerned about is the mosquito biting an infected
person, a person with Zika virus in
their blood, and then being able to
transmit that virus to someone who
doesn't have the Zika virus.
And so we're really worried about the
mosquitoes biting people at this stage and
we're really worried about the numbers
of mosquitoes were going to get over summer.
And we're going to get a lot, and that's
what we're concerned about.
One more question.  May I ask why do mosquitoes bite human?
I want to know if there's any food we can eat to prevent them.  Is there any food that we can eat to prevent
mosquitoes from bitting us?
Well, that's a great question.
There's been a lot of discussion about this, but there has been a lot proven about it.   Again, it's like how do you
keep zombies away? As if we all put garlic around our necks. I'm not really sure.  Some people say, oh if you
take certain vitamins that might.  That's not something we recommend.
But we do recommend is that if you're
outside, wear long sleeves shirts, wear
trousers, because these particular
mosquitoes, they like to bite you on the ankle.
And if they find you,
they'll try to bite you on the ankle.  It's
really important on any area that you
have exposed, use approved insect
repellent.  Follow the directions on the
back of the insect repellent.
On your clothes use that permethrin spray that's part of your Zika prevention pack.
Put that in your pack.  This is how you are going to
make money over the summer holidays.
Trust me, you really will.  And it's really
important that at night we try to keep
the windows closed.  If we have air
conditioning, we turn to turn on.  If we don't,
keep the windows open, but make sure we have screens on the doors because what
happens is when this mosquito bites us,
they can't fly very far.  They can fly
about three feet cause why?  They're  big and
fat and they're full of blood.  And what they have to
do then is sit on a vertical surface for
about 30 minutes to allow the water and
the protein from the blood to separate.
And that's why when you wake up in the
morning, you might see mosquitoes on the
roof on the walls, and they don't fly
very fast.  They're really easy to kill cause they're full blood,
and so it all happens locally.
This is really important to prevent
mosquitoes.  We have to take these actions that I outlined around our house, and that's
really important to do.
So how much blood you think they take from us?
Not very much.  Have you ever been bitten by a mosquito?
Um, yeah.
Did they take much blood?
Yes.
They did?
No they don't take a lot of blood, but they
need that blood because they
need that protein.  That's their food. That's
what they need.  And they need that
protein because for the female, it's only the female mosquitoes that bite us,
they need that protein before they can lay
their eggs.  So it's really important
there are many ways we can break the life cycle.  So yes, do i think I'm going to get
bitten by a mosquito in Washington, DC this year?  Of course, I am. I get beaten every summer.
I can't avoid it.  What I can avoid, if there is
anyone in my neighborhood, if there is anyone in
my street that may have had Zika, they
need to stay inside for at least seven
days and not get bitten.  They need to
tell us so that we know that we have to
be more vigilant.  We have to do to be
more proactive.  We had to take certain
actions.  We have to increase in strength
in what we need to do, and we have to
ensure that, even though we enjoy the
outdoors, use the insect repellent, wear the
proper clothes, spray your clothes with permethrin, ensure you don't get bitten.  And if
you decrease that risk, then you decrease
the likelihood of the Zika being
transmitted and you decrease your
personal risk.  It is all about you.  You decrease your
individual risking from getting the
Zika virus.
I have a question.
Why do you think cases of microcephaly
only started appearing in 2015 even
though Zika was first discovered in 1947?
That's a great question and this is -
we've been discussing this now in the
meetings. I'm on the World Health
Organisation Zika risk communication
team.  We meet twice a week and we are having
these discussions all the time.   We
thought it might have been environmental toxins.
We thought it might have been
related to maybe other problems.  Like
we've seen microcephaly before.  We
see microcephaly in moms that
don't have good nutrition.  You know severe, severe malnutrition can lead to microcephaly.
We've seen - I saw three babies
just recently in teenage moms who had, and
the babies had microcephaly, and the moms had been drinking alcohol during
throughout their pregnancy.  So we know
alcohol and drug abuse can lead to microcephaly.
And so when we first saw
microcephaly in Brazil, we didn't really
believe that a virus transmitted by
mosquito can actually do this.
So why?  On this hand, we had Zika virus.  Over here  we had microcephaly, small heads in babies,
and we didn't know there was a
relationship.  And it's only recently
they've actually found that the virus
can get into people, into these
pregnant moms, and actually can be can go from the blood through the placenta into the baby.
And we've seen now evidence that the Zika virus has been in these babies and attacks the
brain.  And that there's still a lot of
questions to answer.  Why is this not
happening in in a hundred percent of all
the moms and all the babies?   It's not.  It's
happening in a very small percentage.
What makes these small percentage of the
moms that are having babies with microcephaly, what makes them different? At the moment
we don't really know.
Another question from Hawaii.
Um, I was wondering how exactly did the virus get its name?
Oh, it comes in a really beautiful forests in
Uganda,
and I've been there.  So if you go to Uganda, Uganda is a country in Africa, there is a forest called the Zika forest.  Now this virus
lives in monkeys, and so we know the
virus lives in the monkeys in the Zika forest
and we believe the mosquitoes had
bitten,
they took a blood meal, they bit the monkeys, they took blood from the
monkeys, and the mosquitoes got infected.
And we've known this happened in 1947 where
the first people got infected by Zika, and it actually came from the Zika forest in Uganda.
But these mosquitoes are so
good at travel.  They can travel on planes.
They can travel on ships.  And these Aedes
mosquitoes, especially these Aedes aegypti, has really
evolved to live with us.  It loves car tires.  It
loves breeding and laying its eggs
inside car tires and these car tires are all over our community.  It loves laying eggs in buckets of water.
It loves laying their eggs and
bird baths. And so where there are little bits
of water, these mosquitoes have adapted
to lay their eggs in very tiny amounts of water,
and those eggs survive and
hatch, and so it's really important.  It came
from Africa, we believe.  It hasn't
caused any problems, but it went to Asia.
We saw breaks in Asia. It didn't cause
microcephaly.  It's only recently that
we're now seeing these birth defects in
babies.  So again, this is an area of research that
both here at the National Institutes
of Health and the CDC are really actively involved in.
Um, another question.
Is there any progress in finding a cure for Zika?
Yes.  That's a really, really good question.
And again, a lot of times when I deal with
public health emergencies, like Ebola, now I'm dealing with Zika, the first thing that
our government, our politicians ask us, "Do we have a vaccine?"  And we didn't have a vaccine for
Ebola and, right now, we don't have a
vaccine Zika.  But there's a lot of
clever scientists out there that
are doing studies right now trying to
develop a vaccine.  But when we develop a
vaccine, we have to ensure that it's safe,
and that takes a series of trials.  We call this clinical trials and it takes time.  So
even now with this
science that we have, we can develop a
vaccine, but it's not going to be
commercially available.  It's not going to be available for you and I to take for a number of years because
that's the process, that's the cycle, we have to take for these trials to ensure it's safe
and it doesn't do more harm than
good.
So yes, we have the science.  We have the
ability to develop a vaccine.
It's just going to be a few years before we have that vaccine available for us.
We have a question in LA.
Why is it that the female
mosquito bites and not the male mosquito?
That's a great question.
Because she needs the blood to lay her eggs,
and she takes the protein out of the blood, and so she needs that meal.
The male mosquito doesn't need that because he doesn't lay the eggs.  So what happens that
of all mosquitoes, and there's about 3,500
species of mosquito throughout the world,
there's about 300 of these species of mosquito that actually transmitted diseases to people.
In this particular case, we're really
concerned about these Aedes species mosquitoes.
And again, it's the same
across all mosquitoes, it's the females
that need to take the blood.  They get the
protein from the blood so they can go on lay their eggs,
and that's what they need,
and so that's why the female mosquito bites.
And the thing is about these Aedes,
especially the Aedes aegypti mosquito,
and it's evolved with people, it's a really
aggressive biter.  It doesn't just bite you.
It'll bite the person next to you, and then bites the person next to you.  It will bite multiple
people on the same day.  It won't just
bite one person.  It could bite many
people in the same day, if they're in the
same backyard, the same front yard, the
same local vicinity.  So they'll just keep biting and keep taking blood meals,
even in the same day.
I have one more question.
Oh, sorry.
It's okay.
Um, if you have Zika virus during your teens, is it going to affect your pregnancy in the future?
That's a really good question.  At this stage we believe it doesn't because what we're finding is
that people who have the Zika virus are sick for no more than seven days,
and after seven days we've found that the
actual virus is no longer found in the blood.
And so we believe right now, with
the evidence we have right now, there is
no long lasting effect from Zika virus, unless you're pregnant and you get bitten and
infected while you're pregnant, then we're concerned.  Right now I just had a phone call from a
school in Chicago, and they said, "Hey
we're going down to South
America for a school trip. Should we
leave all the girls behind and not take them?"
No, you shouldn't do that.  Again
you got to go and enjoy your school trip.
Don't cancel it.  Go enjoy the school
trip, but ensure that your protected and
you to follow the recommendations for
taking care of yourselves from being bitten.
If you get sick, we know that's what we believe right now, there is no long-term lasting effect.
Again there's still we're still researching this.  We're still asking the same questions,
and many doctors and nurses and scientists are asking the question, so it's really important we
understand, but that at this stage we're saying
there's no long-term lasting effects.
That's a really good question.  What we
have found, which is really amazing,
is that we have found that the virus in men,
even though it's not found in their blood,
the virus can be found in their semen.  And
so what we're recommending now if a man gets infected,
he shouldn't have sex (or, if he
has sex, he has to use a condom) for at
least six months. and that's the
recommendation for the Center for
Disease Control right now.  It might
change as we learn more.
Okay.  My question was, um, what are the likely fatality rates of babies who are infected with Zika?
That's a really good
question.  And we know that we have about -
in the United States
every year about four million babies are
born every year.  We know that even before
Zika, there's about 2,500 of those babies that
have microcephaly.  We have many years of information, many years of data shows that
2,500 out of about four million babies born
every year.  Many of those babies go on
and have normal lives.  Many of those
babies have, maybe, some
developmental problems, but it's not
severe.  When you have severe microcephaly,
like a Down syndrome baby, they
need support for the rest of their life.
And so it's really important that
what we're seeing now is that, even some
babies are born with small-sized heads
at birth, are actually doing okay.  There're doing well.  They're not having long lasting effects.  But there's
other babies have severe microcephaly, severe small sized heads, which means they have severe small
size brains, and they need support.  And
they're having also other problems -problems with
their eyes, problems with their vision,
problems with their growth, problems with their
balance, and it's really important that
we have the programs in place to support
those babies, support those moms and dads and those families.  That's what's really
important.  So we're really worried about
this in countries where we're seeing an
increased number of microcephaly, does
the program at the hospital or community - are those
programs in place to support those moms
and dads with a baby that needs a lot of
support?  And that doesn't always happen.
We have a question from Hawaii.
Do you think that, just like the influenza, the Zika virus can go through mutations, since some cases of Zika are different from another?
Yeah, that's a great question.  Because again, this is what was called an
RNA virus, and we know that with all
these RNA virus, they mutate.
They change a million times a day.  Does
that mean anything?  We don't really know.
Does it make them more
infectious?  Does it change the outcome in babies?
Not really.  But with we're monitoring this.
So it's really important that we have
we have laboratories, we have
universities, we have scientists that are
monitoring the Zika virus in many
countries, because the big concern is that
it's gone to nearly sixty countries now
since 2007.
It's gone to nearly 45 countries in the
last 12 months.  So it's going through
that cycle of mosquito to people,
mosquito to people and, every time it goes through that cycle, it has a chance to mutate.
And it's really important that we stay on
top of this to monitor any mutations.
If we find a mutation, then we had to do
more research and understand what does
that mutation mean.  So again, this is a
concern we had.  This is one of the
hypothesis.  This is one of the ideas that was posed back in Brazil last year in May 2015
when Brazil said, "Hey we got increased cases of Zika in people, increased cases of microcephaly, small
sized babies being born with small heads."
We didn't know whether it was because of a
mutation, and we're not, and so we are still
studying now.  And we can do this with what's called
through genomics sequencing.  We do a
fingerprint of the virus and we see whether
the virus has mutated.  And again, we have
to work at if that mutation actually is
going to cause any problems, and that's what researchers do every day right now.
Well, from King Drew we'd like to thank you Dr. Macgregor.  It's coming to the conclusion of our presentation for today.
Would you guys like to say something?
Thank you.
You're very welcome.
Thank you for warning us and giving us what we can do, right?
Also from Hawaii -
thank you.  Thank you.
We learned a lot.
Thanks.
You're very welcome.